i did a drug called molly right mdma
whatever ecstasy i'm not a big drug guy
i would go to this thing called burning
man but i've never been a big drug guy
in my life right
drink a little bit but i've never done
any like the hard stuff and um
but what it does is it gives you this
super boost of like i guess it's
serotonin or something like that
and it was for the first time in my life
i felt like way
excess feelings of happiness right like
my jar
my tank was full and then some and the
enlightening experience i came out with
it
out of it with was when i had that
excess i didn't want to hold it
i literally was calling friends and
going
oh my god i love you you're the best
this that the that's what i did with my
extra i didn't store it i didn't put in
a [ __ ] bank vault
i did nothing but give it away and i was
like
wow that's kind of cool that if i can
get myself to full
what i'll do without anybody pushing me
is try to get
other people too full you know
and that's a hell of a realization
i don't i don't think i'm i'm alone in
that i think a lot of people i don't
think you are either
i think that's how it is so does that
mean that we're inherently good if we
can just get
too full
probably i don't know
i mean look it does seem to me i you put
your finger on something that's exactly
right there i think is that
you know you had intense enough joy so
that you wanted to share it that's what
happened you didn't want to keep it all
for yourself
and there is intense joy in making other
people happy
i mean look you're a comedian
what are you trying to do you're trying
to make other people happy that's your
goal
why is that so rewarding i mean partly
it's because there's a
there's there's a recognition
by the crowd of your of your value
you're witty you're sharp
you're creative you know and that's
that's reassuring
and flattering but but that isn't
that isn't the essence of it the essence
of it has to be that
that you're there to serve the audience
you're paying attention to the audience
you want their
you want their approval yes but not in a
false way you actually want to be funny
you want to provide something of value
and if that's genuine they're going to
see that in you
especially if you work hard at it and
then that is
rewarding yes yes 100
approval but on my terms right
i i won't go for the easiest thing to
get approval
i often choose the hardest thing and
that is my own little like um
for lack of a better word like
intellectual uh
stimulation that i get from the hardest
thing in what way
uh like i would prefer the topic that is
the least funny
uh so you set a challenge in your path
yes now i know the audience might not
maybe subconsciously they appreciate it
the audience might not know uh on a
conscious level but for me
that's the challenge you know it's it's
like um i saw jack white did a it was
from the white stripes jack white i got
that right right yeah my memory has some
holes in it so and in any case
i saw a documentary he made and he
talked about the way he set up his stage
and
first of all he had this old guitar like
it was just beat to death and it didn't
stay in tune so he had to tune it up all
the time while he was playing or it
would go out of tune
right and then he would put instruments
in places that were difficult to get at
on the stage
and he did all that at least in part
because it kept him sharp while he was
performing he had to pay attention
intense intention to what was going on
and that heightened his that heightened
what what what would it say
because he had to pay so much attention
it heightened his creative ability
yeah his awareness and the intensity of
the performance it sounds like you're
doing something that's quite similar
yeah yeah 100 i almost look at it
weirdly like you know you know diving in
the olympics
you know how like you not only get
judged on how clean the dive was
but also the level of difficulty of the
dive
everybody can just dive straight into
the pool but like if you want to do a
few backflips and then dive into the
pool clean
you know you're going to raise the
stakes and then the the comedians that
i've always looked up to
um and weirdly enough someone who i
think has a lot of a lot in common with
you that is
my favorite ever is patrice o'neill
right and uh the thing about patrice is
like almost to a fault he lived his
truth
so when i'm reading your stuff about
like telling the truth and like the most
adventurous thing you can do
is is tell the truth right what do you
think about that idea it's [ __ ] great
i love it why because i've been really
thinking about that again lately i put a
little instagram clip out from a from a
podcast with chris williamson
yeah and i said you know if because i've
been thinking
all these political movements you know
black lives matter and antifa and
and the right wing identity politics
white white supremacist
types um they're all offering this kind
of romantic adventure right you can
you can join this revolutionary group
and take yourself out of your mundane
day-to-day existence
there's a real attraction in that and
it's very difficult for
mainstream political ideas to compete
with that
because people need an adventure
especially young people you need an
adventure man that's your life but i do
believe
that there isn't any more intense
adventure than saying what you believe
to be true
because you just don't know because you
have to let go of what's going to happen
and you don't know what's going to
happen
and what you said it's true i don't know
if i would recommend it but no
it's certainly not dull it's not dull
and
and
it's not realistic i think in a lot of
ways like patrice sabotage himself
there's a comic named jim norton that
said it brilliantly like he lived his
life
as if he was gonna have to watch a movie
of it
with his three best friends afterwards
like they were gonna be there and call
him out on every fraudulent thing that
he did
right so instead he told the truth so
when he watched the movie with all them
he could be like not that was me i
really felt that way about that person
in that time
right and but the problem with obviously
there are certain problems of telling
the truth all the time like sometimes
the things that we feel are not
acceptable right we might feel something
that's not publicly acceptable
and i think that your workaround for
that was well you don't have to say it
out loud you have to say out loud
everything you feel but
if somebody's asking you something
like what if my friend is like hey how
was my set
this is a person i love a person i want
to do better at comedy do i tell them
that it
sucked that will be the best thing for
them maybe
maybe they'll work harder on the jokes
maybe they'll get better
you know like do i have do i have a sit
down with my mom and do i tell her that
she's
annoying me when she's calling and
asking for help i feel guilty that it's
annoying
that's on me so it's like well but you
can have that conversation too right you
can say
this is a good way of having a
conversation with someone you love it's
like
it turns out that there's something
you're doing that's bothering me
but that might be because i'm stupid
yeah you know you're either annoying
or i'm stupid let's figure it out
because if you're annoying i want you to
stop because i don't want to be annoyed
with you but if i'm
stupid then you should tell me because i
don't want to be stupid
and and that's like you can you can tell
the truth without
claiming omnipotence you know it's not
that you're right it's just that that's
what you think
and so but you you do want to be
corrected if you have any sense because
why would you want to lug your stupidity
forward
yes apart from the fact that it's
painful to confront i mean and it is
yeah but
it's not as painful as lugging it
forward so then you're stupid forever
that's not that's not advisable
you